documentos materiales Y urnas listas
para ser entregadas en los Colegios
electorales de todo el país las
autoridades nigerianas se preparan para
una de las elecciones más importantes de
su historia no hay discrepancias así que
tengan la seguridad de que el sistema es
sólido no lo estamos implementando por
primera vez en la historia lo hemos
hecho en 105 circunscripciones y los
resultados aún están para ser vistos y
han identificado cinco obstáculos
principales que podrían afectar el
proceso electoral la inseguridad el
debilitamiento institucional el desorden
de información los problemas de
identidad y las disputas inter e
intrapartidistas
los nigerianos deberían poder emitir su
voto sin miedo e intimidación y confiar
en que sus votos contarán la aceptación
pública de los resultados por parte de
los candidatos también es vital para
todo el proceso y uno sin el otro
debilita el sistema democrático y podría
desencadenar violencia postelectoral por
lo tanto el rol de la sociedad civil es
garantizar un proceso creíble y
transparente
los analistas políticos estiman que más
de 93 millones de personas asistan a las
urnas Mientras que el gobierno prometió
que se desplegarán más de 400.000
miembros del personal de seguridad ante
la amenaza de posibles interrupciones de
extremistas islámicos a pesar de ser la
economía más grande el país más poblado
y uno de los principales productores de
petróleo de África Nigeria atraviesa una
crisis económica encabezada por la
escasez de efectivo la tasa de desempleo
ya ronda el 33% y la de pobreza supera
el 40%, un problema que se suma a la
creciente violencia Armada en las
regiones noreste y sureste del país y
que deberán ser abordados por quien sea
el próximo presidente de la potencia
africana